we turn to google without even knowing
what we want to ask but we just have
this question regarding like this
general subject and once we start like
researching more thoroughly then we can
have the specific question we wanted to
get to so it's kind of like
i don't want to say like a similar thing
but it's kind of similar
in terms of violence and and healthy
relationships so whenever
we want violeta to become this this
platform that you can turn to whenever
you have a question how to relate
to another person in a healthy way
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel an immediate
partnership with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders we're going
to talk about a really important topic
today and that is violence domestic
violence emotional violence physical
violence any sort of violence
and it is 2021 and loretta meyerson is
working on some new tools to help those
that are
that are in a situation that is not
ideal and need help whether they realize
it or not
she's developing technology to help them
deal with it meet florida mercen
co-founder of violeta floreda was born
and raised in mexico city and at the age
of 18 moved to israel to study her ba in
political communications she is always
aligned by the 2030 agenda as dgs and
has participated in many projects and
initiatives with a social and
environmental perspective such as mess
movement for sexual equity and safety yk
center an incubator and accelerator of
the sdgs and have volunteered for cadena
natural disaster assistance committee
and a girls orphanage since 2012.
loretta mayerson welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you hi michael thank you
for having me here i'm really excited to
be here chatting with you today
thank you very very much i'm really
excited to have you here all the way
from mexico right yeah i'm in mexico
city right now
mexico city great and
we're going to be talking about some
some difficult subjects but but
extremely important ones and your
startup violeta which you co-founded
it's a
cycling and a really crucial problem and
then and i'm always inspired by
entrepreneurs that are tackling these
types of problems and and deeply curious
about the the journey and about what are
you learning about how to effectively
tackle them and i wish there were more
people like you that are that are that
are spending their time and energy and
expertise tackling them and so i'm
really excited to be inspired in these
20 minutes and so i will let you
introduce a little bit of what you're
working on and as well as your journey
so tell me a little bit about violetta
and then we'll go back in time and talk
about your journey as a whole
great first of all thank you for letting
me share this story here it's great to
have this space and opportunity to to
tell about violeta to so many people
um
violeta in a nutshell or violeta if you
want to call it in english
it's a digital platform that provides a
safe space for anyone who's struggling
with any situation regarding violence it
doesn't have to be any
physical violence where we're focused
more on like these invisible patterns of
psychological violence that are really
really hard to recognize violetta
provides this digital space in which
through a chatbot that's powered by ai
you can get all the information you need
to first identify the situation
recognize what you're leaving
get the advice or recommendation that
that's going to help you overcome the
situation and you can also get connected
to the professional help that you might
need being psychological
medical or legal help
wow okay so that's a lot to unpack and
and one let's go
one level higher so tell me a little bit
about
the trend and the problem on a global
level
so that i can get better acquainted with
with the pain point of what you're
solving and then we'll also dive into
how you're actually solving it so what
is happening around the world that that
really bothered you
okay so i think one of the main problems
around violence is not having enough
tools or even like the lenses to
recognize it and identify it because
it's so normalized into our daily
interactions
and there's some some numbers that are
really really frightening for example
that one in every three women around the
world will experience violence and when
you think about this is like we all know
three women you know one of them like
when you when you take those numbers and
actually put them into humans and people
you know it's really really scary but
here we're talking about for each woman
that reports violence or each person
that reports violence how many don't
even know they're living a situation of
violence you know they can't even
recognize it or don't have enough tools
to to look out for help
um and we saw this
kind of
i don't want to call it a trend because
it's a problem that has been going on
for
years and decades but now
we're seeing it
in the news we're seeing it in the local
newspapers we're seeing people talking
about it and bringing the conversation
to the table because i think kobe was
this
mark like there's no going back after
after the pandemic after spending so
much time in our homes in lockdown many
times with the aggressors
and
mental health became a priority as well
you know we're seeing these
topics that we weren't so used to talk
about before and we weren't used to
to put them as a priority we're seeing
them now
being set
as a priority they should be
so it's not something that's new it's
something that has been growing as well
it's it's the shadow pandemic as as many
people call it
yeah as kovat was rising these violence
cases were also rising because people
who used to have
i don't know eight hours at the office
before and it was their safe space they
didn't have them anymore and people who
could go out and reach out for help they
couldn't do it anymore
when we were in in this first lockdown
of the pandemic
so you could see this violence by like
spikes like going exponential
in many in many countries especially in
latin america all the helplines were
over saturated by more than 80 percent
so it's crazy
how
how violence was was happening and it
wasn't being dealt as a priority
you know so this is this is when we said
okay we have to to do something about it
we have to deliver this safe space that
so many people need and it's not a set
like for for many people home is not a
safe space you know so
how can you deliver a safe space when
you're when the
the physical space where you're at
is not safe
and that's when it when we
came up with this idea of digitalizing
trust and digitalizing safety and
digitalizing the confidence of of having
someone to talk to and having someone
there who's always listening to you and
you can reach out for help at any time
or any place you're at
what does that mean to digitalize trust
and digitalize safety
well
when
when we started having these initial
conversations
we wanted always to deliver this feeling
of
talking to a great friend talking to
that friend that's always listening to
you and talking to the friend that gives
you the best advice
and the friend that's never judging you
and never projecting projecting him or
herself to your to your situation
but in a massive scale so how do you get
to thousands of thousands of people at
the same time through technology so we
said let's digitalize that feeling of
talking to that great friend
in order to
to help you understand what you're going
through and to help you
give you the tools in order to reach out
for help
so that's basically what we're trying to
do all the time like if you talk to
violetta uh even though it's a chatbot
you can you'll never feel that it's this
i don't know airline service chatbot you
know it's this very empathic
conversation that talks
to you like first in the pronouns that
you identify yourself with
uh the way you want to be called it asks
you that way
um
it talks to you in as in a very casual
uh language in in a very non-technical
uh yeah way
in order to always arise these feelings
of safety and of
yeah it's like
like a virtual hug in a way
right now maybe can you share with me
the
you know the
the ideal customer journey that you're
envisioning as you're building violeta
what what is an example of a case of
of a customer journey that
that you would expect
for somebody using violeta all the way
from you know having the violence take
place all the way to it being in some
way shape or form mitigated through
violetta
yeah so this is something very very
interesting because most of our users
never come to violet and say hey i'm
living violence or i'm living this
specific type of violence right rather
they say hey i'm feeling really anxious
at home or hey i'm i'm going through
this difficult time with my partner is
is this normal
you know so
i would say the
like the ultimate uh user journeys first
this this
i don't want to call them users because
it's more than that but it's this person
who who knows there's something that's
not feeling right but maybe can't
identify exactly what it is or or what's
making him or her feel that way
they turn to violetta either on her web
app or
or a platform
directly and
after a couple of interactions they can
now have the
the tools to ask correctly what's going
on because it's like sometimes we have
so many so many things going on in our
lives that you don't even know how to
start you know like
which question to ask first
so they come to violeta get some
information violeta will be there
listening
and
giving some
it's not even advice because it's a step
before that it's more like an emotional
contention
and after that
giving the advice that's relevant to
their specific situation answering all
the questions the user the person might
have
and connecting them to the specific
a professional that's going to help them
like outgrow the situation because maybe
it's not the same
if you would speak to yeleta in tel aviv
i cannot recommend you the same
professional as a user here in mexico
you know so
um even even in mexico mexico is such a
huge country
a person living in the city might not
need
the same
you know help that a person living in
the
in in the suburbs or in a rural
community three hours away from the
nearest
i don't know police station so
evioletta can identify like that the the
specific need the person needs
and connect them to the relevant
optimal professional help in a way
so one of the things that you touched on
before is this idea that you know many
people may not even know that they need
assistance or may not even know that
they're in
a situation of violence so how are you
thinking through
you know
getting them on boarded into this chat
that will allow them to even understand
that there's something that's not
healthy happening here and that they may
need assistance to get out of it
that's a great question and it's one of
the main challenges we're facing all of
the time because i could i could answer
that question saying like oh we're i
don't know creating these digital
campaigns to specific users but it's not
as simple as that you know like it's
more of the
the way we are
targeting these people
and the the messages that we're putting
through
and at the end of the day we want
violeta to be this go to tool whenever
you have
a question regarding your relationships
you know sometimes
um
we turn to google without even knowing
what we want to ask but we just have
this question regarding like this
general subject and once we start like
researching more thoroughly then we can
have the specific question we wanted to
get to so it's kind of like
i don't want to say like a similar thing
but it's kind of similar
in terms of violence and and healthy
relationships so whenever
we want violetta to become this this
platform that you can turn to whenever
you have a question how to relate
to another person in a healthy way
right tell me a little bit about you
know the scale at which we're operating
right now and you know a little bit
about the numbers of your letter and
what you've learned that maybe you
didn't know before you started this so
you had some hypotheses and now
that you've been
live what have you learned about this
problem that you're tackling no that's
exactly
the core here like we had these
hypotheses that people would open up
with a robot because it's literally a
robot
with their most intimate and personal
stories and situations
and i remember in the beginning when we
were testing it and we were like
prototyping it
people would tell us like no no one's
gonna turn to a robot like we want this
human connection and it turned out not
to be so true because many people are
looking for a space where they can feel
they're not being judged and always this
human contact has this
bias of the person who's listening you
know and this is very very
unbiased
so
we launched violetta well the first mbp
because we've been operating with an mvp
for the last 11 months
and last november to prove this
hypothesis to prove that people would
open up to this digital safe space
and up until now we've had more than 20
000 unique users talking to violeta
about many different subjects and more
thousands twenty thousand and more than
nine thousand people redirected to the
professional help they needed
so it's this bittersweet feeling you
know because it's
it's a these are great numbers that
prove that people are actually feeling
safe and confident with violeta but at
the same time
this shows the magnitude of the problem
as well
so yeah and many people have told us
like i wish i had violeta a couple of
years ago it would have changed the
situation my story would have been
completely different so
these comments kind of like
prove
or are
our main goal but at the same time they
show how how big and how deep the
problem is sure
take me back a little bit to your
journey and
you know what what do we do what were
you doing before v11
and what led you to know that this is a
company that you want to start and
build so
throughout my entire life without
actually like putting it
in a conscious
way i've always worked on projects
related to the
2030 agenda
um since i was a child like since i was
volunteering in school and i grew up
well mexico city is is a huge city huge
and we have huge problems and huge
opportunities as well right so
um i've always been this person who's
really aware of my of my surroundings
and of them
of the areas of opportunity that come
with this kind of awareness not the
responsibility that comes with this
so i've volunteered with different
organizations in the city that
range from like environmental
organizations to this
girl orphanage house that i still work
with
this committee for natural disasters
so these like various projects that that
align to kind of this 2030 agenda
and then i worked more properly in an
accelerator for the sdgs in israel
actually
and
yeah and then it was when i came back to
mexico after studying abroad i studied
in israel and then i finished my degree
in new york
that many problems became really really
apparent it's like this shock therapy
like when you realize sure
you know i was in an environment that
didn't have these problems and then i
came back to mexico and
wow they became so
noticeable
and
one of them mostly was violence and i
realized how normalized violence was in
my daily life interactions i mean with
my friends with my family
with any people who i would talk to i
would start noticing these violence
traits in language in
ways of talking communicating like
stories they would be telling
that they didn't even recognize they
were violence
and that's when i started like digging
and digging and digging into this
problem and understanding that it
as i said in the beginning like one of
the of the biggest problems surrounding
violence is not being able to notice it
and as a woman in mexico i realized that
i've been exposed to many violent
situations many situations many times in
my life
and i didn't have enough tools to
identify them so
i wanted to give this
space and these tools to people
for them to start building healthier
relationships starting from the from the
core you know starting from their
families from their
relationships because how can we be how
can
yeah how can we think of a country
that's safe
where the first
social fabric which is family is not
safe you know 100 100
and the founding of violeta so you're
saying okay this is a problem that i
want to solve
what do you do then how do you go about
going from you know zero to one from
knowing that this is a problem that you
want to tackle to actually building out
a strategy plan to tackle it
okay so it started in a very funny way
and
i started going to schools high schools
middle schools and high schools with a
basket and post it
and i would tell the students
put all the questions you have relating
relationships related i don't know
sexual safety and sexual education
related like all of these topics that
kind of relate to violence ask away
anything no one's gonna know who who
wrote the question no one's gonna know
yeah who you are
and i remember teachers telling me like
oh no one's gonna write anything
students are very very apathy like they
don't like to get involved into this
kind of project and i would come back
for my basket and the basket would be
full of questions so this started
proving the need of information and the
need of tools and the need of these
spaces where students weren't feeling
judged
and with these like base of questions
that we
that we put together
from many different schools we started
creating the first answers from the
chatbot
and then covet hit this was a bit before
coving
and the pandemic started lockdown
started violence cases starting to get
like crazy exponential and there was a
contest in the in the country for
initiatives dealing with any problematic
of coving
and that's where
my team and i came together we were all
drawn by the co like by the cause and by
this like input of change like we wanted
to change something
and we submitted this project
because at the time it was a project it
was literally a powerpoint presentation
with this database of questions that we
had from schools
and
yeah and and i remember people from the
contest telling us like yeah but this is
not solving like the core problem of
pandemic like it's not talking about i
don't know medicine or food supply or
you know jobs
but it was talking about a problem that
no one else was talking about so we got
to the final of the project like the the
finale and then we got connected to
another project which was a
a contest in china from alibaba
the company
and it was crazy because we were the
only project from latin america
founded by women
talking about a social issue and that
wasn't focused merely on like on profit
so and we got to the top global top 10
of the competition so this was like our
biggest validation you know we kept like
breaking these boundaries of people
telling us like no this is not needed or
this is not going to work
or how are you going to make money and
and it just it has been like kind of
rolling by its own
because there's a huge necessity i
remember once a mentor told us like
there are many problems out in the world
don't invent one because you want to
create something you know like choose a
problem that already exists and tackle
it deeply so i think that's kind of what
we're doing right now
i love it and florida obviously you know
the the inspiration that you have going
into this is just exudes and resonates
throughout this whole talk but what are
a few words that you would use to
describe yourself
if you had to if i were to ask you or
anybody that works with you what are a
few words are represented by florida
i love this question because we so we
when we hear it like the first thing
that comes to mind are like these
external
factors you know external descriptions
but if i if i like slowly think about it
i'd say throughout my life
what like has characterized me is this
awareness i'm worried i'm very awake and
aware of my my environment
i'm very conscious
and i think this consciousness comes
with responsibility so i'm very
responsible as well
wow
florida thank you very very much
both for this 20-minute talk but more
broadly for the work that you're doing
and for the amazing impact that you're
having
and i get inspired by people like you
and the people that are tagging these
types of problems and i can't wait to
follow the journey
and to and to see what happens and how
it grows and how it continues making an
impact and i can't believe you've
already impacted more than 20 000 people
through this it's pretty remarkable and
so thank you very very much stay safe
and stay healthy and and best of luck
with violet and with everything else
that you're gonna be doing afterwards
thank you michael thank you for having
me here it was really great
[Music]
you